at South by Southwest I'll be speaking
on a panel about transit and
accessibility there's a lot of work
taking place to improve access to
transit for people with disabilities and
technology is making it more and more
possible
there's particularly a lot of work in
the space of universal design so can you
make designs that privileged people who
have higher needs that the solutions
benefit all riders one of the things
we've been working on is adaptive
interfaces so lots of people currently
use mobile phones to get transit
information we're using that to learn
the routes people usually take
anticipate what they want so with a
single button press we're only showing
them the information that they want and
if you think about blind riders they
have to listen to all of the information
being read it's very difficult to skim
auditorally so giving people a reduced
set that's almost always exactly what
they want really saves them time this is
also true for people with cognitive
disabilities who struggle more to sort
of figure out what is the needed
information versus the unneeded
information